the honeydew with y'all
thank you for your support here's ryan
sickler
welcome back to the honeydew with y'all
we're over here doing it in the night
pants studios i want to thank you all
for your support this community
continues to grow the stories continue
to blow my mind
um
and please if you or someone you know
has that story that has to be heard
submit it to honeydewpodcast gmail.com
make sure your credit cards are up to
date and if you're in for the long haul
subscribe for a year and you'll get over
a month of free episodes all right i
love you all
um please keep sending your stories you
guys are strong the community is really
something else and today's episode will
be no exception please let me welcome to
the honeydew with you all today ladies
and gentlemen zoey smith welcome to the
honeydew with you all zoe
hi
how are you doing
i'm good
and i i detect a little bit of an accent
so where are you right now
uh i'm in new zealand in the north of
the new zealand yeah in new zealand and
zoe um how old are you
32 32 and what do you do for a living
now i'm a personal trainer for the last
three years did i did you say in yoga
instructor 2 or i make that up
uh no you made that up i made that i'm
on personal training i make up a lot of
stuff
but you're also a mom you told me
correct yeah yeah i've got two two kids
all right
four and six
so
um
tell me a little bit quickly about you
know where you're from originally like
the area and then we'll get into so i'm
from
like a small town i don't know how many
of your listeners know new zealand but
uh from the north of the north island in
new zealand there's about 50 000 people
in my town
and
yeah i grew up here
in the middle of nowhere very far away
from town and
went to school had a normal life have
great parents and yeah my story kind of
takes place in my late teens because my
childhood was very normal and
nice which it really was strange yeah
yeah
i had great parents everyone was nice to
me nothing terrible happened to me i had
good friends i did really well at school
i was like a like a prefect which i
guess you guys don't have that because
it's very english but
yeah i was a good kid and
then i met a weird dude at a wedding
yeah see weddings are no good for
anybody
[Laughter]
so all right we're going to talk about
the age range of 19 to 23 you said and
it all starts at 19 when you met this
guy at a wedding whose wedding whose
wedding were you attending so it was
like
this the weird guy no a guy that used to
rent one of the houses on the property
that we live on okay he moved out and
was still sort of vaguely a family
friend so it wasn't like we were
important people in the wedding we were
the ones that i just invited you know
how there's like but you didn't take a
date with you
no i took a friend okay i didn't know
him at all and we were just hanging out
all right and meet this guy
yeah i met this guy and we were sort of
talking with a group of people and my
ex-boyfriend was also at that wedding
and me and him were good friends and he
saw that i liked this guy that we were
talking to and he had gone to school
with that guy because i was 19 and my
ex-boyfriend and the guy that i met
um were both seven years older than me
so he was like hey i know him
do you know that he's gay and he's hiv
positive and i was like i don't really
care because i'm 19 and i'm dumb and i
don't give a [ __ ] about it you really
did have the attitude of i don't care
well
when he told me those two things he's
gay and he's got hiv the one that pissed
me off the most was that he was gay i
was like damn
like
i was like there goes myself
yeah
and so i was like [ __ ] i really like
that guy and um
and then i was like oh well we'll just
be friends because he was funny so you
believed him though you didn't think he
was [ __ ] blocking or trying to do real
yeah you really did believe him like
we're good friends and he he said and i
know that he was just trying to be like
hey by the way that guy's crazy so like
you know
beware
and i thought oh well who cares i'll
just be friends with him like he'll be
my fun gay friend because whatever but
obviously i still was into him so we
started hanging out that
wedding was in like september which in
new zealand is spring so it was like the
beginning of the summer
and then that whole summer we were
hanging out and secretly i was like i
really like you you're really hot and i
wanna i wish that you weren't gay and
then we got drunk hooked up hooked up
and i was like hey i thought you were
gay and he's like hey like you know
sexuality is fluid so um
he just we just started hanging out and
hooking up so hold on all of my friends
the first time you have sex with this
guy do you wear protection
do you i mean does he do you use
protection i don't remember but i don't
think so
because we were so drunk and
he's like was fresh out of rehab when i
met him it's like a proper alcoholic
like the ones that shake before 10 a.m
if they don't smell a bottle of wine
like the real alcoholics
um which
when i met him he was just out of rehab
so he was like healthy and fresh and
didn't have those symptoms yet but very
quickly went back into
being like that
so the summer was fun because he wasn't
in the depths of his addiction so can i
ask you how was the sex with a guy who
says he's a gay guy how was the sex
pretty good which is probably why yeah
so is he bisexual
i mean he when he was in high school he
was like a cute guy and all the girls
really liked him and he's not like a
very effeminate gay guy were you the
only woman he had sex with no no no no
so he was gay as in
like i don't know he was gay but he
said he always fell in love with women
and he could have sex with women but he
was gay like what turned him on was men
it wasn't
yeah so i felt like i was always
fighting against that and whenever he
would be into me i was like yes like he
must be on a good day or whatever
[ __ ] i like heinz ketchup but if
it's the only thing available i'll take
hunts yeah i hear you
i got you yeah i got you um and
so we were hanging out we'd have a good
time he was well hold on i'm sorry i
know i'm stopping you because my
girlfriend you know he's hiv positive
and but i'm dumb that's fine look we all
are at that age we all have made plenty
of mistakes i mean that's a big one but
we all have made plenty of mistakes but
are you having an open dialogue about it
at all or are you just not addressing it
are you ever asking him are you ever
asking if hey maybe this time we should
put a condom on or
any of that
the thing is is that it was so this is
going to make me sound really pathetic
but it was so hard for him for me to get
him to be into me
that
when he was into me i was like let's not
ruin this with like clinical with aids
yeah okay let's start ruining this
moment with aids
yeah totally i was like i don't want to
ruin this what was going on because this
doesn't happen
and
dumb and like yeah it makes me sound
really dumb and in hindsight i'm like
what's wrong with me but yeah it doesn't
make you sound dumb i'm blown away that
you're being open and honest and sharing
this with people because
people need to know that it's it's okay
to be like yo you know or or also it
could be a nasty rumor that's why i
asked if if you really believed it right
away or or if unfortunately you found
out the hard way so you were at least i
believed it and then i didn't tell him
that i knew that someone had told me
for a while so
how did it come up then
i was just
we were hanging around i was drunk and i
was like hey do you know that um like do
you have hiv because
i heard
and then he was like oh yeah like we
weren't crying and all
saying like i didn't
i told my mom and she told everybody and
that's how you that's how the guy that
told you knows because
he was keeping it a secret from
everybody and he had and confided it to
his mum and his mum had told our very
small community here so very quickly
everybody knew his mind so everybody
knew
i mean thank god but still what what a
purpose
and then he um
yeah so everybody that all of my friends
and all the small community that we
lived in knew and were like what the
[ __ ] is wrong with you why are you
hanging out with this guy like don't you
know we all know that about him it
wasn't like me and him had a secret but
you have you have unprotected sex for
over a month before it gets finally
brought up and then he's crying he
doesn't apologize he never once feels
remorse or he does and he's like i
shouldn't do this and i'm you know like
you're so young and you've got your life
ahead of you and i'm 25 and i'm so old
and like [ __ ] up so
you know whatever and uh
and we just keep hanging out and then
i went back to auckland which is about
four hours away to study and he moved
back there which is it's like the
biggest city in new zealand it's like
the only city that has any kind of city
life you have to realize we live in a
very big country with various little
people
um
and
then i was studying again and
really [ __ ] up my studies because we
were taking a lot of drugs
and
my friends which were a very close group
of friends that we all lived together we
like moved into different
flats or whatever you call it like a
room we've got different houses
different roommates um
because they were like you're
on drugs now and you've got this crazy
boyfriend who's like
weird and what drugs
which is very big problem in new zealand
so
yeah who introduced you to the math
him and his brother so you're getting
aids and meth out of this guy i'm not
such a good guy like it's just it's not
starting off good i'm a big believer in
is not how you start it's how you finish
but i'm thinking you get the kick
holy [ __ ] yeah so you start are you
smoking it are you snorting it how are
you smoking it all right smoking it
first and then
that like
was under control sort of for a while
and i was still studying but we were
partying a lot and then
he was because he had been a prostitute
when he was
younger is that how he got it
i think so or just because he was like
typical this makes me sound bad but i'm
allowed to say it because i would hang
out with a lot of them um like gay guy
who just [ __ ] everybody and didn't
give a [ __ ] and just i don't know how he
doesn't even know how he got it exactly
from who he just got it from his
lifestyle
um and
when i met him he wasn't on medication
yet so i don't know if you know much
about hiv but you
get it and then you are super contagious
for ages and then until you're what ages
how many we talk about years
like yeah it depends it depends on how
healthily you live and how what kind of
where you catch it so whatever if i
caught aids from somebody who was really
advanced then i would jump to their
level wow pretty quickly like you know
so you you start wherever they started
it sort of this is i'm dumbing it down
but basically i understand and um
and then you keep getting blood tests
every few months and when you're i don't
know come over what it's called but
you're like
your cell count gets below yes
yeah that's it then then you have to be
on medication to stop it going any lower
but in those years or however long it
takes for your t cells to get low
you're really contagious and you're not
on any medication and i met him in that
awesome period of his life oh so
of course he was super yeah
um so he's super contagious and now
you're
having unprotected sex you're smoking
meth
and
you begin what work as a prostitute is
that what you're about to tell yes so
it's that how do you do that
first it started on uh
the new zealand version of craigslist
basically
which is um i was just listening to your
new archer guy and i was like yeah like
i was like yeah buddy like i feel you
same thing generous like you use the
same words
and uh
and then so when i see an ad that says
generous that means this is sex for hire
better pay
okay because if you say it explicitly
they'll ban you or they'll take you off
because it's you're not allowed to do
that anyway so about great two or three
years hold on you can't just jump in
into hold on you're
this good girl gone bad you say you had
this great upbringing and then you meet
this wild guy
and now you're smoking meth
why do you decide to be a prostitute do
you need the money is it to afford the
addiction yeah the lifestyle is that
what it is are you not working a regular
job anywhere else
because you're what no sir
um no i i
tested positive for hiv 10 days after my
20th birthday but you also realize that
the age of consent in new zealand sexual
consent is 16 and the drinking age is
18. so whatever you guys think of a 20
year old is like reverse that by a few
years because we do everything way
before you guys do right so you know
if i think of an american 20 year old
that's like a new zealand 17 year old
god
um
so anyway what all right so before we
get to that then let's jump back here
what um
sort of symptoms do you start
experiencing when do you start worrying
that nothing
so how do you find out
because i'm [ __ ] sleeping with an
hiv-positive dude
well i was just i had got tested and
tested negative a couple of times it
took me a year before i tested positive
and even after some negative tests you
didn't think all right i i dodged a
bullet or two here yeah i'm on drugs i'm
partying i'm having a good time i'm like
it's like i'm living it up in and also i
started when i started working as a
prostitute because i had no money i mean
if you're i mean probably the same
anywhere in the world when you're a
student you've got no money where you
get like a student allowance here which
barely pays your rent you're living off
like rice and soya sauce to live like
you have no money you have no fun and
you alcohol is really expensive and all
your friends are studying their asses
off and
and not doing much and i was like this
is dumb i don't want to study that hard
i'm gonna like party lot
okay so
are you an hiv positive
not
prostitute
the beginning so i was prostituting
before i was positive all right so take
me through the first night because
i i mean i'm have anxiety about it
is that where you went in a brothel
no the first couple of times was like
off craigslist talk to me about
literally
sacrificing your body to a stranger i
mean who could easily overpower you
easily yeah anything kill you it's like
i mean you're about to be a dateline
episode new zealand edition
yeah
um so i
made him on the internet on the thing
and then
i lived in like a suburban house which i
was renting with my
friend i wasn't actually living with the
boyfriend at the time but other friends
that we were all studying together um
and i was like you can't come to my
house because my flatmates don't know
that you're that i'm meeting some random
dude and he's like you can't come to my
house because my kids are there and i
was like okay and then uh
he's like you can come in my car and i
just walked down the street
and i was like i'm gonna have sex in the
cast i'm gonna wear a skirt so that i
don't have to like if people because
it's the middle of the [ __ ] day it's
like two o'clock in the afternoon on
thursday so i was like people are gonna
see
um
so i was like i'll wear a skirt because
then i can just straddle over him and
like people will think that we're just
hugging in a car
um
and yeah i got in the car and in the
like middle console he put 200 bucks
which is what we agreed on
and
he was like this i don't know late 40s
indian guy and we just
didn't say much and then he like smelled
really heavily of whatever cologne
and then i just he put on a condom and
like i just
did make him wear a condom i was gonna
ask when i worked i always use the
condom okay because i was like these
dudes are nasty you can catch anything
from these
um not thinking that i was living with a
guy that hadn't had all the things but
yeah
so i always did that and and when you
got done the first time how did you feel
fine i was like sweet i got 200 bucks
are you serious you didn't you didn't
feel like holy crap i can't believe i
did that or any regret or anything
i mean to be like i don't know if like
everything that i've done in my life the
first time i had sex with a boyfriend
when i was younger first time i smoked
weed first time i took any drugs
i never said to the person i was doing
it with
that that was my first time for anything
first time i went skiing i was like this
is not my first time going skiing so
that man has no idea whether that's your
first time or your 1 000. because i
always wanted to be
more experienced than i was in
everything that i've ever done so i
always lied and was like yeah i've done
this before
no matter what it was that i was doing
so
i was very detached and like i didn't
know so then do you enjoy it you start
doing it more often
i never enjoy it but i'm pretty good at
like being like it's like
not it's not traumatizing but it's not
enjoyable it's like i got to go to work
and then i go to work and then i get my
money and then it's fine what's the
riskiest
situation you've been in while
prostituting
so when i was working at a brothel in
auckland which is um
it's like in the gray zone of legality
because prostitution is legal here and i
guess the brothel has to pay rent to the
council for the building that they hire
but also i think they must pay tax on
whatever credit card transactions go
through but obviously most people pay
cash because they don't want credit card
thing
um
and
a guy that came into there was like a
gang leader which new zealand is famous
for very terrible gangs
and he had this like floor length
like fake leather black trench coat on a
shaved head and like missing teeth and
just looked like a horror movie it was
like a white guy
but all shaved and no teeth and big
trench coat smoked a lot of cigarettes
and
he was like he booked me into one of the
rooms there
and what are the rooms like
it's just hotel rooms
no no it's just like a hallway with
numbers and then there's like a little
room that's like
i don't know three by three meters i
don't know what that is and whatever and
it just has like a leather bed with six
towels and a little shower thing with
little bar soap that's in a plastic
thing so that each client gets a new bar
so and like that is that your room or
are you rotating
you rotate so when you get you stay you
hang out downstairs in a bar
and all the girls just kind of hang
around in this bar and the dudes walk in
they can buy a drink
and then they talk to the girls and when
they want to book one
you and the guy go up to like the
counter and then they'd be like are you
in room six and then you go in there and
what are the average age of the girls at
this one at this brothel in new zealand
are we are we seeing chicks in their 50s
and 60s still holding on or
they wouldn't make any money
no it's like
i think i was yeah this between 18 and
35. okay and the ones that are in their
late 30s some might be in the early 40s
are like keeping it together really well
they've got fake boobs which is not
normal in new zealand and they've got
like you know they're
keeping it together pretty well
and how does the transaction work do you
pay a percentage to the house
they pay 250 an hour and i get 120. okay
so you get just
just under 50 god damn they're hitting
hard huh how can i okay um
[Laughter]
and then they're really strict about you
not getting their phone number and
meeting them outside of the brothel and
undercutting them which everybody
[ __ ] does sure but you just you try
to keep it you don't get caught cause if
you get caught then they don't let you
work there anymore and then you have to
go to the city of brothels and nobody
wants to do that and at this time your
boyfriend knows you're doing this and
doesn't have a problem or you're
shutting up about it
no he was his idea
because
you have to realize like
i think in his mind we were like best
buddies we were like
like like a girl and her gay best friend
and i was like i'm in love with you and
i want to have sex with you and he was
like no you're my cool friend we would
get along really well as friends and he
was funny and we would hang out and
laugh and like to say movies and whatnot
but the whole time i was like no i want
to be your girlfriend like i like you
and he was like no we're having a good
time we're partying together like like
friends that party together and then we
get wasted sometimes and have sex and to
me i was like this is how marital
relationships
um
and so he was like you know i used to do
it and it was fine for me but now i'm
too old because i'm 25 so i can't make
you know and girls make way more money
prostituting than boys because
you know it's only old gay guys that
have money that that
hire the young dudes
yeah but there's a way bigger market for
a girl to be a prostitute so like you
could make money
and i did
and then how much yeah what's uh what's
a great night
like two thousand dollars damn
yeah what's the most customers you've
had in a night
uh
nine or ten in one day
yeah so you know my record my record
because they booked for an hour you got
a record
you got a record
no no not for amount but for time okay
so like they book for an hour
and then when you like go upstairs
they're like whatever the lady that met
him like looks at the time and if you go
over time she has a little intercom and
she like buzzes you and she's like hey
you either got to pay another hour you
got to [ __ ] get up the janitor
we're closing girl come on
no it's 24 hours man they never closed
oh um
good lord
they
yeah so but obviously once a guy comes
like he wants to get out like he feels
embarrassed he's like i'm in this
[ __ ] dirty brothel with like he's you
know the road
it was tinted glass so he's like out the
door which i knew i was the [ __ ] as
prostitute by the way i had put no
effort in
i would just lay down and be like
[ __ ] do your [ __ ] and then i'd be
like pay me and get out put in zero
effort and you're supposed to be in
there you're supposed to have a shower
which is also your chance to like check
that they don't have any
horrible diseases oh you shower them
first
well you shower together which is like
part of the warm up and it's i think
they want to see that you've actually
showered because whatever
and then uh
from pain from him paying downstairs to
going upstairs having a shower having
sex having another shower getting
dressed cleaning the room and going back
downstairs 10 minutes
damn
because i was like and then
and then the lady at the checkout she
was like you're back already and she's
like i feel like you need to drag that
[ __ ] out a little bit longer he's not
going to come back and i was like i
don't give a [ __ ] because
i'm not here for regulars yeah yeah i'm
not here to get a roster built for i had
no regulars i got complained about
because i put in so little effort
i never heard about a prostitute
getting written complaints
there were some girls who had regulated
there's a suggestion box over here and
they're like man just tell her to act
like she's alive an experience i'm like
dude i don't do no girlfriend experience
a towel over my face and i'm like
[ __ ] you put a towel over your face
sometimes
i can get away with it
wait what's the weirdest request i i
didn't i heard you mentioned girlfriend
experience i wasn't even thinking stuff
like that guys want you to act like
you're their girlfriend and stuff
oh and i couldn't do that i can't i
couldn't i couldn't do anything what are
they saying they want you to you say you
love them and stuff like that
yeah and like kiss them and ask them
about their day and like
like pretend that you like them
and i think mo
all of my clients knew that i did not
like them at all like i was not good at
this what's the strangest request but i
was
19
to have a really cold shower and lay
down and pretend i was dead now
and then he would like
yeah and it'd be all floppy and like no
that was pretty gross he wouldn't yeah
he wouldn't know that this is pretty
easy because i'm tired
this is right up my ass
it's cold as [ __ ] but
like
give me all the necrophiliacs
i think i found my anger i'm gonna take
a nap just keep them coming
[Music]
that is insane
i was all about like pissing on people
i'm like doing it i'm there like all of
the [ __ ] that's the other thing they'll
pay you to piss on them huh
they'll pay you to do that yeah the
funniest one there was a guy who was
like i want you to piss on me and then
obviously you do it in the shower
because it's like less clean up and he
was like crouching on the ground and i'm
like standing over him and i could tell
he had never done this before it was
like he was like i wonder if i'm into
pissing like let's go and see if i'm
into pissing and as i started pissing i
could see it on his face he was like
yeah i'm not into pictures
and i was like yeah no i stopped and
he's like okay cool and had a shower and
i was like i'm gonna go now like this is
like hey you tried it you tried it
oh my god you're a trip yeah all right
all right all right so hold on
okay
um let's see i'm looking in here okay so
the i'm sorry we we diverted from the uh
[ __ ] keanu in the matrix over there
sam jackson in the matrix the guy with
the leather
the leather uh overkill oh yeah that's
the bald head and the busted teeth late
50s
and i knew like you know he walked into
the brothel and the girls that had
worked there for longer they were like
you know like there's calvin like he's
you know he's serious [ __ ] calvin like
what is the deal
calvin kelvin like the temperature
yeah yeah yeah and um and here they were
like he's the he's the leader of the
headhunters which is like a big
gang in new zealand and i was like i
don't [ __ ] know i'm like i'm little
and i'm white and i'm from a little town
i don't know um and uh
and they were like you know just be
careful of him but then the druggie
girls because there's like almost like a
segregation in the in the brothel of
like the girls who work the day shift
and kind of have normal lives and kind
of are like normal people and then
there's like the druggy ones which are
like hardcore and they
work night shift and they take the crazy
ones
because so yeah so i was dancing the
line between them because i was still
going to university
or college like during the day you were
in that peter
yeah i studied film and television
production
um did you ever did you ever run into
someone you knew
no no but one of my friends that i met
there did her like brother's best friend
or whatever but i lived from a totally
different town okay
and like
yeah no i never met anyone on you all
right um
but anyway so
they were like oh yeah you should be
careful of calvin you know but the
druggie girls were like oh they were
like [ __ ] all over them like moths to
a flame and i was like he's got good
drugs clearly so i'm gonna go hang out
with this guy and uh and then i did i
hooked up with him a couple of times in
the brothel and then he you can do like
an out call so it's still through the
brothel but they
have a driver and they drive you to
wherever the guy wants like a hotel or
his house or whatever and then they pick
you up again and that cost the guy a lot
more and he drove me and this other girl
out
to his house and he used to have
where jeans you know the jeans that
don't have a zip and a button but just
all buttons yes and he would like
yeah a button fly and he wouldn't wear
undies or underpants or whatever you
call them and he would just
unbutton and pull his dick out but not
pull his pants down and we'll be fully
clothed and just do that and because he
took so much drugs it was like
he was just waiting to win the lottery
on being able to get a boner because
he'd be like hanging out with all his
prostitutes that he would get and then
he'd be like oh my god i got a burner
everybody like has to like do something
it's like i can't get one normally
because i'm a [ __ ] drug ass
and then we'll be like oh [ __ ] like we
got to do this for the next five minutes
and then he'd be like oh no it's gone
and then uh
yeah and then i remember i was like
giving him a [ __ ] and i was like
trying to pull his pants down because
the fly kept like getting me in the face
and he was like no like you can't and i
was like jesus christ then one of the
other girls were like he can't put his
pants down his legs were all [ __ ] up
and i was like what and then i was like
well now i gotta see this [ __ ] because
i'm that kind of person so i was like
like slowly pulling it down a little bit
and just at the top of his thigh i
managed to get it down far enough it was
like
like unhealed burn scars oh like
yeah i don't know what it was but it was
like angry
yeah or like eaten away like i was i
didn't smell because i never if i hadn't
pulled his pants down i wouldn't have
known and he didn't know well he
probably didn't go to the hospital
because a gangster and he can't go turn
himself in
other girls who had known him for longer
were like yeah his legs were real [ __ ]
up and like don't ask him about it
because he was the kind of guy that
would fly off the handle if you said the
wrong thing
like
and then he would be scary and then
you'd run and then he'd calm down and be
like why'd you run away and you're like
because you looked like you were going
to murder me so i ran away and then
you'd be like oh calm down i'm not that
scary i'm like yeah you are
but um
but yeah so then we were me and this
girl who was one of the good girls one
of the like day shift checks
were at his house and he had fallen
asleep or like passed out so we were
just sitting on the corner of his bed
at like three in the morning looking at
our phones we didn't know each other we
weren't girls that like hung out when we
were in the brothel
and uh i hear this like
banging from the bathroom because we're
in his house
and i'm like you're now in this guy's
house yeah and he had massive [ __ ]
stereo systems everywhere and like
sandwich ziplock bags full of meth which
and you i don't know how cheap that [ __ ]
is there but that's like 400 000
here
and i was like dude i'm gonna steal that
[ __ ] but then if he wakes up he's going
to kill me so like are you correct i'm
not going to do it so i never did it
because i was too scared i was like he
will actually kill me if i if he wakes
up and i'm halfway out the door with
that thing like it's game over so i
didn't but anyway so we were sitting on
his bed he had passed out and we were
just like looking at our phones and
riding down the clock until our driver
picked us up
and i hear this like bathroom someone's
climbing through the bathroom window
and me and this girl look at each other
and we're like what the [ __ ] so we're
like waking him up we're like hey dude
like something's happening
and these three dudes come in one's got
like a sawn off shotgun and one's got
like a knife and the both of them are
like throw your phones on the bed to me
and the girl and we're like oh my god
are you [ __ ] yourself i'm so
[ __ ] myself and then calvin wakes up
and he's [ __ ] himself which makes me
[ __ ] myself yeah because he's scary dude
i'm like if you're [ __ ] yourself
like what the [ __ ] hold on i threw my
phone and i'm like
and then he's like give me your wallet
and i was like dude i'm a prostitute
like you're a [ __ ] gang so you really
want to take my 200 bucks like what a
[ __ ] [ __ ] which he didn't they
were nice gangsters
he wanted my
he wanted my driver's license so and he
took a picture of our driver's license
and he's like now i know your real name
and i know so
if you you know call if you try to call
the police in days to come or whatever
i'm gonna find you
and like blah blah blah and then you
like put our phones on the side
there was like two three guys the main
guy that was talking and he was like
he said to calvin he's like who the [ __ ]
are these two and he was like oh the
girls they like their hookers they're
from the thing whatever and he's like
well get rid of them because like
they're not part of our problem
and he's like i can't they're going to
get picked up at 6am and this was like
3am you know i can't get them they won't
come earlier and he's like well [ __ ] i'm
you know i'm not gonna i'm not going to
let them see anything and i was like
okay please don't let me see anything
like i don't want to see what you're
going to do to this guy
and then they like made us go out into
the lounge they like went through all
the [ __ ] took all his drugs took all his
money like kicked him and then he was
looking at me and being like don't leave
they're going to kill me and i was like
dude i don't have no like loyalty to you
i don't give a [ __ ] what happened to you
like i'm not gonna kelvin you dude like
if they would pick me up now i would
leave now like i am not gonna stay here
to save you
and then the guy was like
um you know we're not gonna do anything
because me and the girl were so scared
we were like crying and we didn't know
each other we were like hugging each
other being like oh yeah this is how
we're gonna die
um
and then the guy was like don't worry we
don't do stuff to women and children
unlike the head hunters which was the
gang that he was a part of and i was
like okay well maybe i was just hanging
out with the wrong mob i'm [ __ ] the
wrong guy yeah exactly
and he's like don't worry we won't do
anything to you so i was like okay fine
and then they were like killing time
until 6 a.m like going through this [ __ ]
spitting on him kicking him like
breaking his stuff unnecessarily just
waiting for our ride for three hours
beating the [ __ ] out of this guy and
you're sitting there and then and then
they started smoking his drugs and
they're like do you want some of those
drugs i'm like [ __ ] hey
[Laughter]
i'm like hey man if i gotta wait here
like i wanted that [ __ ] anyway so
yeah and uh and then our driver came
which was like this nice guy and we used
to talk to him all the time because he
would take us on long drives he was like
had a family and he would like make good
money better than being a taxi driver
you know like a nice guy who was just
like felt bad for us and would like
sometimes have snacks for us in the car
because he knew that we were like like a
really nice guy and he was like oh by
the way calvin left his
something i can't remember what it was
like his wallet or his hat or something
at the brothel i'm just gonna go up and
give it to him and we were like no no no
like just well you know we're in the car
like don't go up to the house because we
had walked down the driveway and he was
like why not and we're like just just
just don't worry about it like you'll
pick it up next time
and then we drove back and me and the
girl were like oh my god we almost died
but yeah that was and we never talked
about it again yet
yeah and i was like do i call the police
is he gonna be murdered and then i
didn't see him for like two months and
then he turned back up again i was like
i guess they didn't kill you god damn
yeah
so what um
there's more to this here how long do
you
continue to prostitute
so yeah when i was 19 i started and then
i sort of ramped up like it was like uni
was here and prostitution was here and
they like slowly
went like that
and so i just started not going to
university and because we were studying
film like we would have film shoots and
then i would
[ __ ] out of one and so then i would get
kicked off like a film shoot because i
wouldn't turn up and then i would just
slowly like not get
not get in the groups that were like
making
student films and things so i just kind
of faded out and everyone kind of knew
that i was a [ __ ] up and they just
yeah i just stopped going
and uh
and then i was working really hard out
my drug habit and of course my boyfriend
was taking all my not taking my money
but like
we were buying drugs together with all
the money when i'd get out of work and
then he would take heaps of drugs and
like
he turned up at work once and i'm like
in my [ __ ] lingerie at the door he's
like germany morning i'm like the [ __ ]
man like you're out partying and i'm in
here working my ass off like [ __ ] off
but of course when i finish work i was
like yeah here's money
so tell me about um you said you were
having um
sex with heterosexual homeless runaways
tell me about this you put this on email
it took a couple of years before me and
him lived in the same house and he would
live in this other flat about i don't
know 10 minutes away with a friend of
his
who was also a gay guy and he like
worked in a restaurant and he
and those two were both like degenerates
and would take a lot of drugs and just
hook up with random people and just be
like the worst stereotype of a gay guy
you can imagine
um
[Music]
and then
jay which was his friend that lived with
him
um
he used to take in
like homeless runaway bought i call them
boys but they were probably i don't know
17 to 22.
and jay was like in his late 30s
um
and be like i'm a nice guy i'm giving
them a place to stay i'm like giving
them food and stuff and they're homeless
obviously they he wanted to [ __ ] them
and he wanted to like see them naked and
[ __ ] and i would go over to my
boyfriend's house which was also this
guy's house and we would all hang out
and party and drink and take drugs and
whatnot and then some of those homeless
guys would want to hook up with me
because i was 19 and cute and
like young and a girl and so then they
would be like you know zoe you should
you should hook up with them because
you know you can and then they'll be
naked and then we can see them naked and
then i was like okay because i was
wasted and whatnot but then i would like
hook up on the lounge on the floor with
these like
dudes and then they would sit on the
couch and jerk off
and it was pretty gross
yeah and the guys that you're having sex
with are into this too
yeah because they're like
they're living on the street and i
like i i make it sound like i was this
crazy drug addict which i was but i kept
my [ __ ] together like i had not clean
skin i had my hair done all night i had
money i had like you know i went to the
hairdresser i had nice clothes i was
young and like skinny teeth are falling
out from the mess my teeth aren't
falling these are all my real teeth
yours your skin looks amazing especially
yeah i know you said you got your lights
on properly and everything but still for
someone who's smoking how long did you
smoke meth
four
three four four years four hours holy
[ __ ] but then i started shooting up myth
as well which oh like tell me about that
how do you get into that
well because like
you get it and it's like either looks
like
like salt like table salt which is very
small or you get it and it looks like
uncrushed himalayan rock salt you know
it's like kind of pink and rocky and
that's the good [ __ ] that's the uncut
[ __ ] and we never really got that that
much and then one day me and my
uh rupert was his name i don't care if
you know his name um he
he got and he's like well and he used to
shoot up but he didn't really when we
were together and he's like man this is
the really good [ __ ] we should we should
shoot this up and i was like okay
because like whatever again me being
like i've done that before and you're
already hiv positive at this point
pretty much yeah by the time i was
shooting up all right so let me go back
one step here so do you have to inform
your clients that you're hiv positive or
do you just make them wear protection
you don't tell them
nobody tells you that technically i mean
legally at that stage
and regardless of prostitution or not
prostitution yes i do
but in the brothel no one asks you
anything you don't get tested you just
get like they you have to wear
protection
sometimes guys want to pay you extra in
the room to not wear protection but
nobody like it's like don't ask don't
tell like the people who work downstairs
in the office that as long as no one's
complaining like they know that people
are taking drugs upstairs they know that
[ __ ] that shouldn't technically
shouldn't be happening is happening but
they just don't they don't ask
man i mean i just think it's a good
practice to treat everyone like they
have aids and have sex with people like
that well i mean when dudes in the
brothel were like i'll pay you an extra
200 bucks to not wear a condom i was
like what the [ __ ] is wrong with you why
would you want to have sex with me i'm a
hooker why do you want to
pay to be even riskier yeah
i was like this is what is wrong with
you so um
yeah and
so we started shooting up in new zealand
you have like needle exchange i don't
know if you guys have that some places i
think they do actually yes here they
have the clan prostitutes collectives
they have like everything is super
supportive like you can go and get clean
needles so i never we never shared
needles i had old needles
because
it's so easy to get clean ones they're
free and like you can pick them up
everywhere
so yeah i started doing that and
and yeah so when there were these
homeless guys in the
in the thing
in the house like they were freshly
homeless they weren't like
you know with long beards and hair
because they'd been there for 20 years
they'd been they had run away from home
like three years ago um
and yeah they were like
i'm not hooking up with with cute girls
because i'm a homeless dude and here's
this cute girl in a house that wants to
have sex with me like of course i want
to
um
who cares that these gay guys are
jerking off over the top of it like
man you have lived a [ __ ] life
absolutely we're talking about this is a
four year span right
um
yeah so what starts happening with go
ahead
no no you were gonna say i was gonna say
with your health things like that like
how are are you um how are you dealing
with the hiv and are you a doctor so it
doesn't really
no i wasn't animate i didn't start the
meds until
long after we'd broken up i basically i
started meats when i got pregnant
um
which was years later
um
and i didn't have any any health things
i was you just feel normal like you
don't feel anything you just feel
the same like if you didn't get tested
you wouldn't even know
until this day i've had no symptoms of
anything it's just blood tests that tell
me that i hit it
and um
and yeah and then
like the drugs got really out of control
i lost heaps of weight and my mom was
like
you know i would still see my mum
sometimes because i'd come up to visit
her and she knew that i was with this
guy she knew that i was on drugs but she
didn't really ask because she was like
trying to keep contact with me and not
push me out completely
and uh
and then yeah just got super out of
control and
and
like then i went to australia which was
a whole another kettle of fish
because what did you do in australia
so there's like the biggest brothel in
australasia which is
like has like 150 girls working in it
which the one i worked in in auckland
was like 12 girls
um and it's this massive three-story
building with like cleaners and so you
don't have to clean your own room like
it's a huge operation
um and are these women from around the
world are you seeing asian women and and
i mean in new zealand not so many but in
australia there's more but there's also
black girls and british girls or you see
not that many but some but some yeah
um
and
yeah and there were some girls that i
worked in
auckland with and they were like hey you
should go to sydney because that's where
the real money is plus the exchange rate
between australian dollar new zealand
dollar was really good so you're like
doubling your money for the same [ __ ]
um so i was like cool i'm going to do
that i went there
composition was
what is the what is the interview
process to get hired at a brothel this
brothel in australia that's it
that's it that's it they don't
they don't call the old place and be
like hey and she have any complaints
like yeah she gotta she got three or
four let's let's step it up a little bit
your driver's license like your id
because i don't want to get in trouble
and you're uh and
photos and that's it
so you quickly got in then and you were
when you went with a job
i went with a job a friend of mine that
i worked with um that i met in the
brothel and we were like
made friends
we went over there together they have
like an apartment building be like a
whole apartment building behind the
brothel where all the girls that come
from out of town like can live for free
in this apartment building that
apartment building was [ __ ] out of
control nice isn't it nice or no
no it wasn't bad it wasn't gross it was
just like
a [ __ ] whole apartment full of
prostitutes oh one apartment
no a building like there's maybe six to
an apartment and then so use all four
story like six live like
why is that not a reality show
so you work [ __ ] should be you work
in this building here and then you live
in the building behind you go down and
across the street that's the passcode
and you're an apartment 2c and then
you've got that room and you can stay in
there while you're working here and
that's it
and um because brothels are 24 7. so you
like
you know they give you your shifts and
you can go and sleep in the like blacked
out rooms in that thing when you're not
working
and uh
and yeah and then i started working
there realized that the competition in
australia was way higher like the chicks
are way hotter and i was like oh [ __ ]
like you know this is some serious like
i might have to roll over here yeah
i might have to take the towel off my
head
[Laughter]
and that's where i met the like chinese
drug dealer guy who like booked they had
rooms that were like the size of an
apartment with three beds and a full bar
and a pool table and a spa pool and a
stripper pole and a stage and like a
whole [ __ ] like it was like an apartment
but like a paint like a
like a playboy thing penthouse yeah yeah
so we were up in there me and my friend
from new zealand with this guy who was
like this little his his nickname that
he gave himself was ninja and he was
like this little fat chinese guy
and
he
just like gave us heaps of drugs didn't
even really want to have sex with us he
just
we just drank heaps of alcohol he's
actually kind of fun that we just made
these crazy cocktails because we had a
bar that we could just do whatever we
wanted in and
yeah we were up there for hours and
hours and then he was like
hey um if you meet me when you finish
i'll drive around the block come and
meet me and i'll pick you up and i'll
take you to my house and i'll give you
more money and more drugs and whatever
so we're like cool let's do that
it's a good idea nobody knows that we're
even left the country of new zealand so
like if we die in australia no one will
even know where we are
um so let's do that with this guy and we
went to his house
took heaps of drugs what's his house
like what was it like pretty flesh like
suburban sydney
but nice house big house like all new
furniture and you know pretty clean and
fancy
um
and by this stage like we had been
working all night it's like 11 a.m and
we were all kind of coming down off the
drugs being like yeah because this
party's kind of over like can you bring
us back to the apartment building now
um he's like oh we should go and get
thai massages because that's a really
nice way to like come off drugs i'm
gonna give you some xanax and then you
can go and get a thai massage and like
loosen up all your muscles and [ __ ] and
be so we were like that sounds like a
good idea
which i had never taken xanax before i
don't even didn't know what that was
that's not a thing that you have in new
zealand
and he was like just take half of one
and me being the little junkie that i
was was like i'm gonna take two um and
they're like two milligrams
each so he was like take half so one
milligram so i'm gonna take four
milligrams
um and i just passed out getting a thai
massage
and to the point where the lady had to
go and get him and my friend and be like
yeah like she doesn't she's not standing
up anymore like we should she should
take her away
they i don't remember but they took me
back to that apartment building
and then i kind of came to and then i
was like this feels fun like i'm all
loopy and weird because i am awake and
i'm on xanax
so i was like let's go out like let's go
wander around sydney on like thursday
afternoon this will be fun so we started
getting dressed like doing our hair and
[ __ ] and then i just fell asleep again
and dropped my hair straighteners on the
bed that i was sitting on and then like
woke up because
the building was like the fire alarm was
going off wow thing was on fire and i
had set the bed on not on fire but it
was like smoking really hard so the so
the thing had gone off and there was
like a fight like a
fire
guy had come in and was getting us all
out and all the hookers were out on the
street half naked like
i'm like what the [ __ ] man i'm trying to
sleep in between my shifts like what the
[ __ ] is this chick doing you imagine
ryan bought out with your kids
and they're all pissed off and like hide
asleep being like what's going on i'm
like i'm sorry man
that's a sign of prostitution you don't
get to see kids so then i got kicked out
of that brothel because they're like you
can't burn down there like check them
out
yeah so they were like you can't work
here anymore and then uh and then i just
went and stayed with that guy with that
chinese guy
um
when did you end it with your boyfriend
when did that finally end
so well i moved into we moved into heaps
of different houses in auckland we moved
into this one house
which had
normal nice people in it like you just
kind of
they advertise for flatmates and we went
there and they were a little bit younger
than me so i was about 22 23 at the time
they were like 21 and they were
the kind of people that i would have
turned into
and kind of am now if i hadn't got into
drugs and i saw like what could have
been my life in them and they were like
studying they were into music they were
like doing heaps of art they were having
all these cool art shows they were
making movies and i was like man that
should have been me like if i hadn't
done all this and i kind of fell in love
with one of my flatmates he didn't like
me because
it made me see myself through his eyes
i'm like why don't you like me and then
by seeing his being like you're a
[ __ ] junkie like well i don't like
why would i like you you're a horrible
junkie chick and then i was like [ __ ] i
really am because i hadn't
had someone kind of reflect it back on
me and show me for what i really was
until
good for you for actually seeing it you
know a lot of people are in denial and
will never look in that mirror
well he was the mirror because i was
like why i'm cute and i'm young and he
was like no you're you're gross like
you're a you're a [ __ ]
meth addict like why would i like you
and then i was like yeah there it really
is like that and then my boyfriend who
was living with me in that flat he was
like you really like me and i was like
yeah and then he went crazy threw a wine
bottle at my head like smash which i
ducked and didn't hit me and stole my
car and i was like okay that's it i'm
done and then that was it and then i
rang my mom and i was like i'm done and
then she picked me up and then i lived
with my mum
for like six months and then i went
traveling and then yeah and are you
married now i was i we divorced like six
months ago
sorry
no that was my choice i'm [ __ ] happy
how did you meet your husband
uh i was a horse wrangler in croatia
what the hell haven't you done
yeah a [ __ ] horse ride who even says
that sentence i was a horse wrangler in
croatia
how do you go from wrangling penis to
wrangling horses
so
so i went to berlin i lived in berlin
for a year and like partied a lot and
wasn't the sort of art scene in berlin
and then
uh a friend of mine
had been woofing i don't know if you
know what woofing is no what's that it's
willing workers on organic farms so you
like work for four hours a day and they
give you room and board so you like like
travel
experience kind of stuff and he was like
i had been whooping at this place in
croatia you know he's looking for a
horse wrangler because i used to be
really into horses when i was young um
and you should ring him he might have a
job for you for the summer and so i rang
him and highly exaggerated my horse
skills to get the job
of course you do
of course i did i was like yeah man i
know how to break in horses i know how
to like ride
whatever carts with them and everything
um and then i started working there and
then i met my husband there he was
working there he's from serbia and we
were like hanging out there
we met in may i got pregnant in
september but you were you were clean
and sober then though right oh yeah by
by for about two years already then now
did you tell him about your past i did
you
so listen everything that you've told me
today does he know
yeah
how soon did you tell him all of that
pretty soon because he was really into
me and i wasn't really into him at the
beginning and i was trying to scare him
off so i was like i'm gonna tell you
some [ __ ] that's gonna make you not like
me anymore and so i told him all that
and he wasn't scared off and i was like
okay maybe this guy's all right
and then we started hanging out and we
had a great summer and then i got
pregnant we got married moved back to
new zealand
had so we
we
met in june and by the following june i
had our son
so like it was real fast
and had moved to new zealand and got
married
and then yeah we lived here in the
country back where i grew up like in the
little house on the commune had a normal
life and you said your children and your
husband have never tested positive for
hiv
so if you take the medication throughout
your pregnancy then you give birth they
have to wash the baby immediately and
then the baby has to take this like gel
paste stuff for like a month and then
they're fine wow
and now what is it yes you said you do
again um
and now i'm a personal trainer personal
trainer that's fantastic good for you
yeah zoey it's like super normal this
has been uh you need it
you need it this has been a hell of an
episode you're you're certainly
something else i really really
appreciate you coming on and being so
open and honest and that was and sharing
your story um thank you so much
and all of you out there if you or
someone you know has that story that
needs to be heard please submit to
honeydewpodcast gmail.com thank you so
much for your support i love you all
this is such a fun community it
continues to grow and i really love this
show i genuinely absolutely love this
show and i love talking to you all
we'll talk to you all next week
[Music]
my
[Music]
you